let's put this Subway sandwich it is my  signature sandwich  it's called the danger witch the  dangerous and it's dangerously good you  have a knife or something be careful  though it's spicy I doubt you made it  that spicy  well tent though  is it in a pita you ever done anything  dangerous  I watch on Sunday Night Football all the  other night actually  subject myself to a lot jeez that is  dangerous yeah trust me  I've done something like that too what'd  you do  I will tell me about anybody okay what  was it listen one time never mind that's  too dangerous what what's in the  sandwich anyways  my danger witch  it's only in the vault oh my God